going to do in this video is begin to
practice subtracting decimals and we're
going to build up slowly and in future
videos we're going to learn to do this
faster and faster and doing it for more
and more complex situations so let's say
we have three tenths minus two tenths
what is this going to be well there's a
bunch of ways you could tackle it I
encourage you to pause the video and try
to do it on your own before I work
through it with you but I'm assuming you
you did that so let's do it together so
you could view this as three tenths and
then we're going to take away two tenths
so if I have three of something and I
take away two of them what am I going to
be left with well I'm going to be left
with one I'm going to be left with one
tenth and we can visualize this let me
put a hole there and this whole is
divided into tenths and we see that
three of the tents are already
highlighted so these three green bars
you can visualize is three tents now we
want to take away two tenths so we want
to take away we're going to take away
one tenth and then we take away two
tenths and so what are we left with
well we're going to be left with this
one tenth right over here that's the
only tenth that is left of these three
tens
so now let's build on that idea and try
to tackle more complex situations so let
me deal let me delete this and this and
let's say we want to tackle one point
five or one and five tenths and from
that we want to subtract zero point
seven or seven tenths pause the video
and see if you can figure this out so
there's a couple of ways you could think
about this and I'll tell you the way
that I do it in my head you could view
this as so let me rewrite this you could
view this as one plus five tenths minus
seven tenths minus let's see
blue color - 7/10 and so there's a
couple of ways that you could view it
you could view this as ten tenths one
hole is 10 10 so this is 10 tenths plus
five tenths minus seven tenths minus
seven tenths and so you could say this
is 15 tenths if you're doing it in your
head you might get to this faster you
might say hey one point five one in five
tenths is the same thing as 15 tenths
minus seven tenths minus seven tenths so
15 of something minus seven of it well
15 minus seven is going to be eight so
this is going to be equal to 8/10 so the
way I just did I just thought of
everything in terms of tenth something
even one and five tenths you could view
this as if you could somehow put a
fifteen in the tenths place and instead
call this zero ones and fifteen tenths
and then you subtract seven tenths from
those 15 tenths to get the eight tenths
which would be 0.8 or 8/10 now another
way that you could thought about it
let's go back to this step right over
here I could have said well look I can
think about what one minus seven tenths
is going to be so I could use as one
minus seven tenths and then I'm going to
add five tenths to that so then I'm
going to add five tenths to that so one
minus seven tenths one is ten tenths so
if I take seven of them away I'm going
to be left with three tenths so you
could say that's going to be three
tenths plus five tenths plus five tenths
which is once again it is equal to eight
tenths now another way that you could
tackle this and once again I'm showing
as many ways as possible just to
appreciate but these are just different
ways of tackling the same idea let's
draw a number line here so let's say so
let's say this is 0 and then 1 2 3 4 5 6
seven eight nine ten that is one one two
three four five that is one point five
so we're going to start at one point
five right over here so that's one point
five and we're going to take away seven
tenths so one way that you might do it
is you say okay let's we could take away
we could take away five tenths which is
a tickets to one and then we have to
take two more tenths away which is going
to take us to eight tenths or 0.8 so the
way that I just thought about it just
now is I said hey this is the same thing
as 1 point 5 minus 5 tenths minus 5
tenths minus 2 tenths the reason why I
broke it up like this it's like okay one
point five or one in five tenths minus
five tenths that's pretty
straightforward to compute you could say
that right over there is just going to
be one I'm taking away the five tenths
and then I have two tenths left over to
take away so one minus these two tenths
and once again you are left with eight
tenths so these are all perfectly
legitimate ways to tackle this problem
and this is a way that many people
including myself would try to do it in
their head